make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right fYI just so you guys know the
next two weeks are gonna be a little
hectic for me so a video schedule videos
might be a little like scattered in
terms of when they come out
but this coming weekend I'm going to the
Ultra Music Festival then the weekend
after that I'm going to Wrestlemania and
after that is clear sailing but until
then it's gonna be kind of crazy but in
the last video the the really kind of
what we picked up last when it came to
the Incredible Hulk is the Incredible
Hulk ended up in hell now if you're
curious how that happened go check out
the video is kind of a lengthy
explanation for the general gist here is
that what al Ewing kind of established
is that a Marvel Comics there's what's
called the one below all and the one
below all is kind of like the opposite
of the one above all right it was just
kind of what you would expect given the
name but well the one above all is a
creator of all things al viewing kind of
runs with like this sort of
judeo-christian mythos which is to say
that like the one below all is kind of
as essentially like Satan and the one
above all is like the God of Abraham is
really kind of what's being hid out here
and it's kind of a bold move to sort of
adopt like the the DC Comics stance on
like gods and so on and so forth and
throw it into Marvel Comics but the idea
here was that somewhere along the line
it will actually find out in this story
when that was but somewhere along the
line the one I'm sorry the one below all
basically intended to like gain access
to the main universe by virtue of a door
that was opened during the original
gamma bomb explosion of Bruce Banner you
know when he basically became The
Incredible Hulk and so where he
essentially kind of like entered in
where he was we're really kind of like
pulled into the pulled into health when
the door was open by like the absorbing
man says he was being used by the one
below all what this means is that at the
moment they're basically walking around
hell now the cool thing about this is
that no matter what you guys see in this
story all of this tape basically takes
place in health but at the time that you
know as this is kind of going on valuing
kind of rights in that these really
really cool series of questions worse
things like what is how supposed to be
what it does it kind of plays into the
notion of the worst kind of hell is your
own personal health one that like you
can't share with anybody else works just
you by yourself in during torment like
for all eternity and so it's kind of
crazy
you know how this how this sort of
unfolds but what it also does is it
basically switches over to the absorbing
man now I remember
the Azzurri man crusher creel used to be
a guy who could only absorb like
tangible materials right so like metals
and and rock and you know plastics and
and water different things like he got
absorb ultimate kinds of things and then
like become that thing but one of the
things al Ewing kind of built on here is
an absorbing man has the ability to
basically absorb gamma radiation
and that's one of the things that Bruce
Banner kind of picked up as a byproduct
of like their fight or at least you know
kind of a kind of a change on his
character but because of the fact that
absorbing man had basically been used by
the one below all for the purpose of
like opening the gamma-ray door again we
didn't exactly know what that motivation
was now if this seems kind of ambiguous
and confusing to you don't worry because
it'll all get cleared up by the end of
the story we can't really explain yeah
but it is kind of a cool little thing
because he's basically met by the
arrival of puck no we have no idea why
pucks here touch one of the guys from
Alpha Flight but one of the things that
ends up going on as they basically go
through this version of help they kind
of end up running into these characters
who have essentially like passed away
but the difference is that like they've
been sent to hell for some reason or
another and what they're basically
running into are kind of like these
copies of them the difference here is
that like the various people with the
Incredible Hulk while they don't know
they do kind of know where they're at
the thing they struggle with is like
letting go but it's one of the things
that they're really kind of failing to
realize here but at the same time it
kind of makes sense because historically
speaking in Marvel Comics when somebody
enters into the afterlife which is to
say like once someone dies and passes on
it's possible to retrieve them but it's
kind of a viewing toying with that idea
something that's like potentially
possible here the other part of this is
that of course with general Thunderbolt
Ross dying The Incredible Hulk
didn't know this and in fact we don't
really know exactly how Thunderbolt Ross
died we know that he's dead we know that
like in Captain America he's dead we
know in this he's dead and it's kind of
cool to see the whole thing happened but
what it does is it creates like a hell
Red Hulk right like a red hell hole it's
like this really twisted mutated version
of the Red Hulk
that's just like rampaging and facing
off against the Incredible Hulk himself
now again one of the things that happens
here is because they fall to a multitude
of times before and because this is not
really the Red Hulk he's not as powerful
as he normally is and so for the most
part the Incredible Hulk overpowers him
and literally like shuts him down quick
fast and in a hurry and like tears his
body in half so for the most part it
ends pretty quickly and so from here
what we do is we switch over to Brian
Banner and Bruce Banner kind of being
kept in in like a stasis of sorts what's
kind of been shown here consistently is
that like Brian ban or the father of
Bruce his abusive father is like the
ghost that torments him it just won't go
away but that's actually not the case
but whether this conversation between
the two what it does is it basically
kind of explains what's going on with
the nature of Brian Banner in terms
like how he functions and so on and
that's one of the big differences here
is that this is in a way Brian panner
but not truly it's it's it's Brian
banner in terms of his forms and
memories but it's also Brian banner in
the sense that like he's possessed by
the one below all but what Brian banner
basically says is that he was one of the
world's leading leading scientists when
it came to gamma radiation and that in
studying gamma radiation and in studying
like what it was possible and what all
could be done what he ended up doing was
having this dream where he basically
witnessed like this green door in what
lay beyond it and what laid beyond it
was basically this kind of like this
demon entity that nobody had ever seen
or heard of before but with Brian banner
kind of having this this sort of torment
you know having this fear based out of
it the other part that came with that is
his anger towards Bruce and what did
what it almost kind of seems to do is
create a corollary when the two are in
Title II separate that when it when it
came to Brian Banner he was raised in a
household where he was abused all the
time he never knew anything but just
like hate and torment and abuse and so
when his wife came along suddenly like
he knew what it was like to be loved the
fear was that when his child was born
that like he would take the love away
from from him like his wife would love
the child more than she would love him
so we're sort of Al Ewing's way of
coming along just saying like yeah like
Brian Banner was like literally hated
his son because he was afraid his wife
wouldn't love him anymore and how did he
do that by literally beating the crap
out of his wife and pushing her away it
was kind of a screwed up tormented
perspective of himself but that's kind
of what he looks at when he looks at
Bruce's he's kind of like that's the
nature of things like like I'm screwed
up you're screwed up the whole nine
yards and so what we end up finding out
here is that as they're kind of climbing
their way up to the top of this tower
basically where this green light emits
from that the one below all is waiting
for them that the one below all
basically intends to use and in
attendance like enter into the main
Marvel Universe using the body of Bruce
Banner now it's kind of cool here the
reason why the one below wall intends to
do this with Bruce Banner specifically
is that when Bruce and the Incredible
Hulk
entered into help they split basically
they split into two different two
different beings which of course we've
seen happen before but for Bruce it
works because of the fact that Bruce
banners body is the only one that can
really withstand that much
gamma-irradiated power that the one
below all uses now in terms of how
crusher creel tied into this the idea is
that with crusher creel there needed to
be a means to essentially open the door
that was crusher creel he was really
nothing more than just somebody running
around and siphoning off gamma radiation
from people and then in turn like
siphoning it off the Hulk and then
being taken to like the original launch
site for the Incredible Hulk gamma bomb
and then in turn opening the door that's
really kind of how that played out like
that was that was the whole basis behind
the actions of absorbing man go around
absorb everybody's gamma radiation and
then open the door
that way the Incredible Hulk will
inevitably follow you follow you in
because he's gonna want to know what's
going on when he arrives here him and
Bruce Banner will split I'll take the
body of Banner and then I'll go into the
main Marvel Universe now the question is
what would happen if the one below all
did that but we have to assume if the
one below all is the antithesis of the
one above all that it has to be equally
powerful which of course begs the
question why can it not escape its own
dimension so again there's a few caveats
here in terms of you know some some
questions that we still need to have
answered bye bye al viewing himself
that's really what kind of goes on is
that in order to basically deal with
like you know kind of keep the
Incredible Hulk at bay while the one
below all does is does this whole thing
what it does is send like a veritable
army of demons facing off against the
Incredible Hulk now of course Rick Jones
kind of regains himself to a degree and
then like fights off against you know
against these demons with the Incredible
Hulk and then of course Rick Jones
basically dies but in the process the
absorbing man essentially absorbs like
all the gamma radiation he can like all
the gamma radiation that was put in
there and then in turn like blows it
back into the Incredible Hulk and so
what this means is the Incredible Hulk
is supercharged The Incredible Hulk is
back to where it was before but also
more powerful and amped up because of
all this gamma radiation that he's
essentially siphoned off from like
everybody else right like that was the
basis behind the Incredible Hulk he was
a guy who was about a byproduct of gamma
rays but what the Incredible Hulk is
doing now is he's running around with
the gamma rays of like everybody who's
ever been an Incredible Hulk it's an
amped up Incredible Hulk and when that
happens like when the Incredible Hulk
gets that amped up he fights the devil
like he literally fights he fights Satan
but he does he does unleashes like this
massive clack and like dissipates this
cloud that makes up the the one below
all and then in turn like he just kind
of you know vanishes for a little bit
now one of the things that al Ewing hits
on is that like the Incredible Hulk
did not actually kill the one below all
there's no way he could because the one
below all is just so astronomically
powerful that all the incredible hoax
done is just kind of dissipate him and
buy them a few minutes enough to be able
to basically like travel to the doorway
and return back to earth but that's
basically exactly what happens like the
two of them just kind of you know dim
alongside like like sasquatch and puck
and everybody else just basically like
travel through this this barrier back in
the name of a universe but again it
wraps up pretty fast
not a whole
doing here I mean it's a cool little
story but it's more of one of those
things where just kind of wraps up quick
fast and in a hurry
but the overall gist here really kind of
the big takeaway from what it is that a
Ewings done is he's created a whole
nother cosmic entity you've got it being
who who presumably is on some level
equal to the one above all but it's
absolute opposite and so that begs the
question if the one below all can only
jump into the bodies of those who can
basically house gamma radiation and can
withstand its power basically being
Bruce Banner then what would happen if
the one below all travelled into the
main Marvel Universe successfully
arrived would it be like to our mom
we're like everybody's gonna die and
there's no two ways about it you know is
is is that how it's gonna play out is
that how it's gonna go down
we don't really really know here ah but
it is cool and it is pretty interesting
ooh that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]